in the back to comfortable, never before has a trip
in a chicken in the back been so comfortable,
joyful only time, but if from the
moment of departure,
well, almost 12 hours,
calmly delayed him a honey cake, convenient and
not comfortable, of course, it gave us a
rest at home,
there weren’t enough places, there
were a lot of children and old people  but
there are a lot of people in total, so
it was decided that it was impossible to even load people with
trucks,
but everyone wanted to leave, and
so, well, there were people left that there was no
place even for the background to judge people for a
very long time, they kept us
looking for a bunch of reasons for the shock, only to delay the
column and not let them in and waited until
the latter, as they say, until it got dark,
and then they gave us a corridor for
a month, two elevators each, and once we spoil it,
then on the 16th we decided to
take a walk, it doesn’t let the city die,
but it turned out to
speed up the men,
well, you’re hurt, you
drag out the
evening, and then someone
drove the buses and like  yes,
it
was more fun
to shell everything this case central no
trill hunger adele
invited the
ranks of the kambarka